Rewrite the expression
below applying
the commutative and associative
properties of addition.
And then show that
both expressions
yield the same result.
So one, we could just evaluate
the expression the way
it's written.
And then we can
kind of mess around
with it using the commutative
and associative properties
of addition.
So let's first add 17.5 plus 3.
So that's going to give us 20.5.
So this is going to be 20.5.
And then to that, we're
going to add negative 7.5.
Now, adding negative 7.5
is the exact same thing
as subtracting 7.5.
So this is going to be equal
to-- the 0.5's cancel out.
And then 20 minus 7 is 13.
So that's our first way
of getting the answer.
And we kind of adhered
to the parentheses.
Now let's use the
commutative property.
The commutative
property tells us
that the order doesn't matter.
We can commute these
numbers around.
They can move, commute.
It's like you're going to work.
They can move around.
So let's just move
the numbers around.
Let's make it--
actually, we could
do all sorts of crazy things.
We could just change
the order here.
We could make this negative
7.5 plus 17.5 plus 3.
We could keep the
parentheses, just like that.
So we would have
essentially just changed
the order of this
expression right over here.
But let's use both
the commutative
and the associative properties.
So now we've commuted
everything around.
And now we can
re-associate everything.
So instead of putting the
parentheses like that,
we could put the
parentheses like that.
So that's what the
associative property tells us.
So let me write this down.
So associative
property of addition
tells us that a plus b plus
c-- we do a plus b first--
is the same thing as a plus b
plus c, where you do b plus c
first.
The commutative
property tells us
that a plus b is
equal to b plus a,
that you can move
these guys around.
So let's evaluate this one.
We actually got here
using both the commutative
and the associative property.
So we get negative
7.5 plus 17.5.
This is the exact same
thing as 17.5 minus 7.5.
It might be easier for
you to realize, OK,
I'm adding two numbers
of different signs,
so what I could do is take the
difference between the two.
And since the larger
number is positive,
I have a larger number.
Or you could just view
this as 17.5 minus 7.5.
So 17.5 minus 7.5--
the 0.5's cancel out.
17 minus 7 is 10.
So this part right
here becomes 10.
And then we still
have the plus 3 there.
And that, once again, is
going to be equal to 13.
And we could keep
commuting this around
and keep re-associating it.
No matter how we do it,
we are going to get 13.